buonasera a tutti e sono molto felice di
essere qui anche se purtroppo solo in
video mi sarebbe veramente piaciuto e
sarà roma insieme a voi ma come potete
immaginare di questi tempi viaggiare è
qualcosa di un po più complesso che il
solito sono anche felice di essere qui a
parlare dell'importanza delle azioni
individuali
noi come campagna per gli obiettivi di
sviluppo sostenibile crediamo molto in
quello che chiamiamo effetto farfalla e
cioè che la singola azione può portare a
un cambiamento e alla trasformazione ma
fino a prima della pandemia
il tar c'era molto scetticismo su quanto
un'azione individuale potesse veramente
cambiare la nostra società
in realtà la pandemia su questo ci ha
aiutato in quanto vediamo con un virus
che ha messo in ginocchio tutti i paesi
dai più potenti ai meno potenti ai più
deboli
l'unica strategia che funziona è quella
delle azioni individuali e cioè
indossare una maschera mantenere il
distanziamento e lavarsi frequentemente
le mani per cui questa pandemia in
qualche modo ha dato un nuovo impeto al
ruolo che noi come individui possiamo
svolgere nella nostra società per
affrontare anche dei temi più complessi
dei temi globali che ci riguardano tutto
e questo stesse strategie potranno
essere utilizzate anche per ottenere
degli altri cambiamenti non solo fermare
una una pandemia ma anche migliorare i
nostri consumi ma anche ridurre le mille
emissioni ma anche acquistare prodotti
che vengono veramente prodotti tramite
delle delle catene delle filiere
siano sia equo nei confronti del
trattamento dei lavoratori che è anche
sostenibili dal punto di vista
ambientale
e poi c'è un'azione la più importante a
mio parere di tutte che quella del voto
attraverso il vuoto noi possiamo
esprimere un cambiamento e nel momento
in cui se un volto solo non conta la
molteplicità dei voti può portare a un
cambiamento radicale all'interno di un
paese per cui sono molto convinta che
questa nuova enfasi sull'importanza
della zona individuale ci potrai aiutare
non solo a superare kobe e tutte le
difficoltà di adesso ma anche a
costruire un mondo che sia più giusto
che sia più sostenibile e e chiedo a
tutti voi di in qualche modo fa è un po
come la svendita è ora di agire adesso a
iniziare a portare avanti delle delle
azioni che vadano nella direzione di
scegliere a partire da noi un mondo più
giusto e un mondo più sostenibile
attraverso il volto attraverso quello
che noi acquistiamo o scegliamo di non
acquistare perché inutile il modo in cui
noi andiamo al lavoro in ogni modo in
cui ci spostiamo all'interno delle
nostre città e anche il modo in cui noi
includiamo non includiamo le persone
nella nostra vita in modo in cui noi
diamo una voce a quelli che non ce
l'hanno e il modo in cui noi in qualche
modo non accettiamo più dei dei
cambiamenti o dei comportamenti della
società che non vogliamo come la
violenza la discriminazione
l'odio per cui tutto può partire da noi
nella consapevolezza che naturalmente un
cambiamento di società implica anche
politiche nuove
indica anche investimenti
e direzione dell'economia in una certa
in una certa svolta
io sono molto ottimista io credo come
molti che siamo in un punto di svolta
che può portarci a una societa piu
giusta e piu e piu sostenibile e i
governi hanno oggi una quantità di
risorse e uno spazio decisionale molto
ampio come non è avvenuto da decenni e
spero che questo che questa possibilità
venga utilizzata nella direzione giusta
e anche noi come individui
abbiamo tutti una possibilità attraverso
le nostre azioni di diventare di essere
di spingere il futuro che non vogliamo
vedere grazie